[Music]
[Music]
and the fact that everybody thinks
they're right is surely an indication
that there's something wrong with the
very idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what we're thinking about or the model
we're using of the theory is very much
going to influence
how we perceive that reality but the
reality still exists
[Music]
if my guess is if you were to ask q anon
people who subscribe to q anon
they should exhibit none of the habits
of mind that you would
associate with a relativist
good evening and welcome to our debate
on
nothing but the truth we have become
increasingly aware
of the importance of culture language
history and identity in determining
our beliefs and opinions yet most remain
convinced
that their own views and opinions mine
for example
are not just culturally relative but are
the true and accurate accounts of the
way things are
should we conclude that all forms of
relativism are a mistake
and insist on the importance and need to
identify the true
version of events and the correctness of
our own outlook
alternatively are some beliefs such as
morality and politics contextual
while science remains objective or are
all views essentially perspectival
in which case do we have to give up on
the very possibility
that we can be ultimately right about
anything we've got
three brilliant speakers here to
illuminate the nature of truth as the
evening gathers
and these are first michael schermer who
is a
science writer founder of the skeptic
society
editor-in-chief of the magazine skeptic
and a presidential fellow at
chapman university where he teaches
skepticism
he's published 20 books including his
newest
giving the devil his due reflections of
a scientific humanist
published last year hillary lawson
is a post-post-modern philosopher and
renowned critic of philosophical realism
who's best known for his theory of
closure which puts forward a non-realist
metaphysics arguing that we close the
openness of the world
with our thought and our language and
finally
jennifer ratner rosenhagen is professor
of history at the university of madison
wisconsin
and is known for her work on nietzsche
and the transatlantic flow
of intellectual movements her books
include
american nietzsche and the ideas that
made
america which was published in 2019.
so first we're going to start with
michael and michael i am going to ask
you the concise yet
tricky question um are all forms of
relativism
a mistake and you'll have three minutes
are all forms of relativism a mistake
go forth yes in general i would say so
because the word has become so loaded
with the idea of subjective truths
and lived realities as is valid as
objective truths
or external truths that can be verified
by other people so let me
just spend my time distinguishing
between those kinds of truths if we
ask what is truth anyway well depends
what you're talking about if i say
i think dark chocolate is better than
milk chocolate
and you say no no i think milk chocolate
is better than dark chocolate well
there's no experiment we're going to run
and determine who has the right answer
these are just internal subjective
preferences or
uh or subjective feelings or emotions we
have about a particular in this case
food product
or if i say i think the greatest rock
song of all time and stairway to heaven
which i happen to think is the greatest
rock song of all time but maybe you
disagree with me and you say
no no it's whatever free bird or
something like this there's no
uh experiment we're going to run to
determine the truth these are internal
truths and
and from there we can kind of build out
to like well if i say i'm in favor of a
progressive tax
and you say well i'm in favor of a flat
tax and somebody else says i'm in favor
of a regressive tax
uh again that's not the kind of
objective empirical truth that science
can determine that's what
democracy is about elections are about
and and the party in power is going to
be the one that you know imposes that
particular tax preference something like
that
but on the other hand if i say well um
the earth is about 4.6 billion years old
and the young earth creationist says no
no i think it's about 10 000 years old
uh the truth is not determined by you
know adding them up and dividing by two
or you know your your lived experience
of a ten thousand year old
earth is is equivalent to mine based on
geological evidence that it's
4.6 billion years one of those is just
wrong
and it's the young earth creationists
they're just wrong about this
and it's not like um the fact that
geologists don't agree exactly
you know 4.56 4.57 you know there's air
bars
but they agree largely within that so
here i define truth as a claim for which
the evidence is so substantial
it would be unreasonable to withhold our
provisional ascent
so provisional is the key it's a small t
there are no proofs in science like in
mathematics or
capital t truths like in religion
we have to always have to keep an open
mind but on the other hand we don't have
to keep running experiments about apples
falling down
because it's provisionally true that
gravity exists
now how do you go from subjective truths
to objective truths well if i say for
example
meditation works for me it makes me feel
better my headache goes away
my stress levels go down and so on
that's a subjective truth
but people that meditate many my friends
for example claim no no it's more than
that
that we can prove experimentally
empirically by measuring blood pressure
and stress hormones and heart rate and
subjective
uh reports of anxiety or depression or
any of these measures such that if you
know we could we could recommend
say you know one hour of meditation
every day six days a week
will cause the following percentage of
people to have these
improved health measures something like
that that would be a move from
a subjective truth to an objective truth
and in science that's what we're trying
to do we're trying to get at something
that
it's not just internal to me you can see
it you can measure it i can measure it
this other lab over there can test it
and we can have open uh disputation and
debate about it
because sometimes the uh it gets kind of
messy and particularly in the social
sciences about what's true but that's
why we have to have open
dialogue fantastic great and we'll hear
more about that in a moment
um hillary i will turn to you um will
you let us know please
uh from your opinion from your
perspective are all forms of relativism
a mistake well thank you
uh well some forms of relativism are a
mistake
but i want to argue that an awareness of
the importance of perspective
is a primary lesson for us of the last
hundred years
now belief in objective truth is very
beguiling
it gives us the sense of progress
knowing where we are
but i would argue that over the last
century we have uncovered that it's an
illusion
and in the current climate a dangerous
illusion at that
now stephen hawking towards the end of a
brief history and time his
account of the contemporary scientific
story of the universe
puts forward the idea that maybe just
around the corner there's a grand
unified theory which would
account for everything and in it he uses
in his words as
this might enable us to see into the
mind of god
of course it's a rhetorical move on his
part he didn't believe in god
and and but what he's trying to say is
to express
as it were the fantasy of objective
truth that we can arrive
we get there and we know how things are
now towards the end of his life he
moved away from that in favor of a model
theoretic account
in which different physics accounts of
the world are seen as models
and we try and improve those models and
we try and get them to be better
but there isn't a correct one or at
least um
we can't assume that there would be a
correct one
and uh in that in holding that view he
was in good company i mean heisenberg
took a
similar sort of view when when he
founded quantum mechanics uh and most of
contemporary
science with it uh back in the uh 20s
and uh hawking in taking this
outlook is really i would argue at the
end of an arc in the 20th century in
which
those gradually seem to be an uncovery
of
evidence for the importance of
perspective
and um you know it started with um maybe
frozen's golden bow and listing uh
belief systems across the world and
that becoming apparent there couldn't
really be one that was true
uh to it invading our thoughts about
morality and fundamentally
the idea that language changes the way
that we understand the world so that now
we see
ourselves as when we have an outlook as
that outlook is a function of
history culture uh our language
and of course a function of fact that
we're human you know we think in human
ways a bat would not think as we do
so the idea that you know these this
perspective which has all of these
constraints
can somehow reach through and find out
how reality
is absolutely uh it seems to me to be
implausible now it doesn't mean when we
conclude that that therefore anything
goes
that we can adopt as sort of well i can
just come up with any old theory and uh
and propound that as being true because
we have to get
our accounts of the world to work for us
and we
we can test those theories not by
somehow uncovering nuggets of facts
but we test them by seeing whether if we
operate according to that
they work or not and this final thought
i'd like to make which is one which i
think is frequently
mis misunderstood which is that being
aware of the importance of perspective
and there being different perspectives
on the world and not being an ultimate
one
doesn't mean we can't argue for and
challenge fundamentally
those views that we think are misguided
or indeed abhorrent
all it means is we can't simply respond
to them by saying
i'm right and you're wrong instead we
have to use those
rather unfashionable strategies of the
enlightenment empiricism
and rationalism to point to what it is
about our perspective
that has things going for it and why it
is valuable
and um uh and in that way
i think we've got uh the potential to be
in a better
space in future where we respect each
other's perspectives but at the same
time
are tied to looking very closely at
whether they work or not
great thank you so much hillary and
finally jennifer
would you please let us know whether all
forms of relativism are a mistake
let me start by saying that i assume
that i was invited to participate in
this conversation because i'm a
historian
not a philosopher though i'm a historian
who focuses on the history of philosophy
and by that historical view has shown me
how relativism is a pretty baggy word
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas